In the name of the Father and of the Son and of the Holy Spirit, Amen!
The reading from the Sinaxadion for September 17th, on which we commemorate the Holy Virgin
martyrs, faith, hope and love and their mother, Sophia.
On the 17th of the month, we celebrate the memory of the Holy martyrs, Pistis, Elpis,
Agape, and their mother, Sophia.
These Holy martyrs dwelt in Italy in the reign of Hadrian in the years 117 through 138.
They came of a rich and devout family, and their mother, Sophia, brought them up in the
faith, hope and charity of the names she had given them.
The Lord of their admirable manner of life reached the Emperor, who, hearing they were
in Rome, sent soldiers to bring them before him.
Considering their tender years, he was amazed at how steadfast in the faith Sophia's daughters
were, and thinking it was only by supporting one another, that they were able to hold their
own against him.
He put them to the question separately.
Pistis, who was twelve years old, was brought in first.
She boldly dismissed the tyrants' flatteries and deprecated his shameless deeds and vain plots
against the Christians.
The infuriated Emperor had her stripped, mercilessly beaten, and her breasts torn off.
Wentz milk, not blood, flowed forth.
The other tortures she endured were to no avail, for she was protected by the power of God.
When at last they came to strike off her head, Sophia encouraged her to accept with joy,
the death that would unite her to Christ.
Elpys, who was ten years old, was brought in next.
Confessing Christ, as steadfastly as her sister, she was beaten and cast into a raging furnace,
but its fire went out on touching her, in whom love of God burnt with a fiercer flame
than material fire.
After many other tortures, she too died by the sword, giving thanks to God.
Agapi, the third of the sisters, was then summoned before the Emperor, whom anger had
mattened.
She was only nine years old, but of the same steadfast mind as her sisters.
She was hung on a gallows and chained so tightly that her limbs were broken by the bonds.
She was then thrown into a furnace, from which she was delivered by an angel, and finally
beheaded.
Sophia rejoiced in spirit to see her daughters so gloriously making their way to the abodes
of the righteous, but overwhelmed by earthly sorrow.
She gave back her soul to God a few days later, at their tomb, through the prayers of our
Holy Father's, O Lord, Jesus Christ our God, have mercy on us and save us.